>> Laura: TIME FOR A SEEN AND
UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE EXPOSE
WHAT'S REALLY BEHIND THE CURTAIN
ON THE STORIES OF THE DAY.
WE LIKE THE WHOLE THING.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW TO SIGN
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW TO SIG
SIGN.
FIRST OFF, THE NUMBERS MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT THE TV NETWORKS ARE
NOT EXACTLY UNBIASED WHEN IT
COMES TO COVERING THE PRESIDENT.
HERE TO EXPLAIN IT ALL, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
WE NEED A GRAPHICS PACKAGE.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
YOU ARE KIDDING ME, THE MEDIA IS
ANTI-TRUMP?
SHOCKED!
>> THE MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER
BROKE THIS DOWN LOOKING AT
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY.
THEY SPENT 1400 MINUTES ON THE
RUSSIAN STORY ALONE.
AND FOR SO    GUESS HOW MANY MIU
AND FOR SO    GUESS HOW MANY MIE
AND FOR SO    GUESS HOW MANY MIS
THEY SPENT --
14 MINUTES ON RUSSIA.
1400 MINUTES ON RUSSIA.
13 MINUTES ON THE ECONOMY AND
TAX.
>> Laura: THE ECONOMY IS DOING
REALLY WELL.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE JOBS NUMBERS THIS MONTH, WAY
UP.
FEBRUARY JOBS NUMBERS.
>> IN BETWEEN THE STORMY DANIELS
STORY WE COULD DROP IN A COUPLE
OF STORIES ABOUT HOW TRADE AND
TAXES --
>> Laura: THEY DON'T WANT TO
SPEND ALL THAT TIME ON THAT.
NOT THAT SAM LUNDBERG GOT --
>> HE WAS A DISASTER.
IF 50% OF THEIR PROGRAMMING WAS
SAM.
ALL OF THEIR EVENING PROGRAMS.
>> Sean: THERE IS THIS
GRAPHIC.
EVEN DAN RATHER, YOU KNOW IT'S
BAD WHEN EVEN DAN RATHER IS
SAYING MAYBE IT'S EMBARRASSING.
WHAT'S THE FREQUENCY COMMAND
>> HE LOOKED LIKE HE HAD A FEW?
>> Laura: NOT SAM WHAT'S EVEN
UP TO?
DR. PHIL?
>> WITH A WIFE ON DR. PHIL.
>> Laura: LET'S WATCH.
>> DID HE COME HOME AND SAY
GUESS WHAT, I'M GOING TO START
WORKING IN THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> NO.
WE ACTUALLY NEVER REALLY TALKED
ABOUT IT.
>> YOU DIDN'T DISCUSS THIS WITH
YOUR WIFE?
>> NO.
HE'S KIND OF LIKE AN IMPETUOUS
GUY.
IN MANY WAYS THAT'S GREAT AND IN
SOME WAYS IT'S TOUGH WHEN YOU
ARE MARRIED.
HE'S REALLY DRIVEN, HE'S REALLY
MOTIVATED, WHICH I ADMIRE, BUT
IN SOME SITUATIONS YOU MIGHT
WANT TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
>> Laura: WHY DO WE CARE?
WHY ARE THEY ON DR. PHIL?
>> THIS IS THE LONGEST
15 MINUTES OF ANY WHITE HOUSE
EMPLOYEE EVER ENJOYED.
THE MAN WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR 11 DAYS.
OF COURSE SEAN SPICER WAS THERE
FOR SIX MONTHS, HE'S NOT ON
DR. OZ OR ANYTHING.
WHY IS HE SHOWING UP?
>> Laura: ARE WE DOING COOKING
WITH ANTHONY?
>> I WAS HOPING THEY WOULD GO
THROUGH WITH NOT THE DIVORCE BUT
AT LEAST THE DIVORCE PROCEEDINGS
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING MAYBE
JUDGE JUDY WOULD GET A CRACK.
>> Laura: NO.
NO.
WE HAVE JUDY?
>> OUT.
DID YOU HEAR WHAT I SAID?
YOU KNOW WHAT I I AM LOOKING AT.
JUST GO!
>> Laura: I LOVE JUDGE JUDY.